this program is brought to you by emory
university i think people are
comfortable at this price they don't
like it but they're comfortable and they
start planning for some some summer
vacations I think if gas prices go above
four dollars and head towards the 450
range then we'll see a big impact and
travel so I think that summer travel is
going to be strong I think the people
are going to be driving and I believe
that the gas prices are going to stay
relatively close to four dollars I don't
see it going much lower than 375 380
something like that which i think is
where it's at right now so I think it
would be a real bonus for us to go into
a big part of june with gas prices below
375 but i don't see that happening but i
think that there's going to be a lot
more last minute travel options to take
a you know two hour flight somewhere
where they didn't think that it would be
possible so i think the long term trips
are going to be you know four or five
our car trips and then a lot more sort
of last minute let's fly up to New York
for the weekend kind of thing I think
that people are a little bit too too
scared to make those commitments because
you know i think the international
flights are relatively expensive i just
love the car industry right now i think
that that they're coming out with
products that actually makes sense i
think a lot of firms I'm had a really
good wake-up call and are actually now
engaging in profitable production
obviously new homes people aren't buying
new homes they really aren't I think
people are very very weary of you know
new construction they just don't want to
commit to that they're not able to get
mortgages we still haven't cleared out
the right prices for four homes so real
estate home construction these are
businesses that usually summer is you
know key for them I just don't see that
happening the preceding program is
copyrighted by emory university